thank you
foreign
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
hello Walter Martin we're continuing
with the same story The Letter yeah
the movie about Lauda to see and its
impact I wonder what Martin Luther would
say Martin
when he received the paper ball he said
it belongs on the dunghill of pebble the
cretels I wonder whether he would use
Choice words like that in the time that
we are living in I am sure that actually
is very fitting no no no you're naughty
now well I'm also a Martin sir yes you
are a Martin let's open with a word of
Prayer
our heavenly father
we are living in serious times
and we ask that you please enlighten our
minds to see through all the nonsense
out there that we can still know that
you are in charge and you are a God in
Jesus name amen amen
I think from the outset it is important
that we understand
that there is only one God and beside
him there is no other
that is of utmost importance and then he
also says in his word see I tell you
ahead of time so that when it does
happen you will believe
it is a prophetic book and it tells us
what is going to happen
and as it unfolds before our eyes
we should be turning to the one God
where there is no other
but the world
has provided a smorgasport and a
compromise as we have spoken about in
the past and this compromise has to
reach a climax
and even if the pendulum should swing
the groundwork has been laid that it
will swing in the direction of paganism
within Christianity
rather than the true word of God because
man does not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth
of the Lord
so call for Unity around climate crisis
is this a climate religion this is what
we started talking about in the last
episode
so let's continue with this story
so let's go back to a clip from the
letter
creation is
religion the experiences that one has
underwater or in this world if you take
the time to just be quiet and listen and
look make you always wonder who's in
charge and how everything got here
like you look at the science
and you can despair
but we also need the stories we need the
narratives that that Faith brings the
motivation in order to to take action
every major faith has taken up the
challenge of addressing the
environmental crises and they do so
through their stories and their
narratives
the first big meeting of the faiths
with the major environmental groups was
in 1986 in Assisi
in Italy the birthplace of Saint Francis
we had all the major conservation
environmental groups there and we had
representatives of the five major
religions
and the theology that underpins Lauda to
see is about calling us into a deeper
communion with the natural world
there has never been an invitation from
a pope to the rest of the religious
world and the secular world
to become Partners side by side in
addressing a major issue that is unique
that's the turning point
in the way that Pope Francis starts this
encyclical well he calls it laudato sea
praise be from the Canticle of creation
but then the whole first chapter
practically is dedicated to Saint
Francis of Assisi thank you
Saint Francis as a Mystic had that
intuition of the created world
Luna
still
now
he died
Francisco
Francis it's the first Francis in the
history of the Catholic Church
nobody dared to take the damn fences
because it's a challenge
it means that you will follow in the
steps of Saint Francis
foreign foreign
I can say even in my small way that this
is what I have experienced in my life as
a Franciscan
the the joy of possessing nothing but
enjoying everything
Martin I am at the loss for words
this is the worst form of paganism that
you can be presented with
brother son
sister Moon
that's the old Pagan Sun worship and
moon worship
takes you all the way back to Babylon
everything is taken back to Francis of
Assisi the guardian of nature I thought
God was the guardian of nature I thought
God was the creator who is this Pagan
entity that supposedly wears a Christian
grab that he should receive on us he
knows nothing
is dead
he is in the grave
and mutton this is what the world
believes
and the Earth becomes a deity and the
creation story according to the pope is
a mythology
so I assume that he is a infidel
biologist geologists geneticist whatever
you want to call him
because the Bible refers to the creation
account
in virtually every chapter yeah the
Bible refers to a universal flood and
Jesus confirms it these people deny
everything these people are
the enemies of God
and spearheaded by the Jesuits
and here comes this man and names
himself Francis
the guardian of creation
Martin is there a plan is there an
agenda that they have written in their
script for everyone to read and nobody
sees it I think
this is the culmination
of centuries of actually 6 000 years of
Satan terrorizing the Earth
this is the final because now
he is against the true creator so now
he's put in a false guardian of Creator
I think I have to agree with Martin
Luther
that the letter
is part of the decretals that belong on
the Roman dunghill
I agree that is the letter that we have
to study there's only one letter
and if they speak not according to this
word there is no light in them
so Martin when they talk about Assisi
and when they had that gathering at the
Vatican
at Assisi where all the religious
leaders came together and I remember I
gave lectures many years ago about the
event of commemorating Assisi and all of
these religious leaders sitting on the
stage there already there was a push for
the unity and the Very fact that they
called it Assisi
which is a link to Francis is already a
precursor for what was to come yeah this
thing has been planned for a long long
time I mean we'll see now but the
Canticle of creation that Francis of
Assisi wrote wasn't the 1200s now if
they're all sitting there in that long
row at the Vatican
the Dalai Lama and all the religious
leaders and you know the Earth religions
all represented what if you put across
the screen there's no other name under
Heaven and Earth whereby you may be
saved would that not put the cat amongst
the pigeons it does I haven't put it in
but there's that whole news story in
Germany now where there's on the top of
that church where they restored that
building and that text that was put
there by the medieval King in the
Reformation time period and there it
stands that there is no other name under
Heaven and Earth whereby you may be
saved and the Parliament is erupting
because how dare you make a statement
like this has the mind of the people
been prepared for sure for the times
that we are living in for sure so
imagine the choice is between no other
name
and I remember that Jesuit priest who
wrote the book called no other name with
a question mark and then he proceeds to
tell you that there are many names
whereby you can be saved directly going
against the Bible
it's scary because they've actually
succeeded just like you said now these
days
everybody can be saved in their religion
there is no organization
that is so evil
and so corrupt and so deceptive
to have ever walked the face of the
earth and the Jesuit order it doesn't
exist there are the enemies of God there
are the enemies of righteousness and
they are the enemies of humanity
and the sad part is they do everything
that it seems they're doing it for God
it's so distinctive but they're doing it
for another God because their words
speak for themselves their actions speak
for themselves and their sanctimonious
gob is only there to fool people so
let's have a look at the second clip
that we have here on the letter and it's
quite lengthy but then we have set the
stage for our further discussion
is
here
but um
foreign
Como
Jose glonies
agrita
momento is
foreign
has lived on this planet and watched it
and observed it for thousands of years
we've learned a lot
we didn't call it ecology
we didn't call it conservation
we just felt that somehow here there was
something more wonderful and mysterious
and majestical and Powerful at work so
we called it sacred
and I think we need to bring that sacred
back
tapping into that deep need to feel that
there are some places
where the veil Between Heaven and Earth
gossamer thing
foreign
because the first time I I see
this Relic
Saint Francis had a special attraction
to Rocky places like this one
in complete Solitude he needed to renew
his contact with the very source of his
life
they needed the conduct with the
absolute the transcendent
is Meaningful for everybody not just for
believers or Christians
so we need to have a Transcendent reason
to care for the creation
modern it comes to mind that the Bible
says they worship the creature more than
the Creator
doesn't it true
and all the religions together it
doesn't have to be Christian he's
teaching the young people that the Bible
is a book of myths from which you can
take a few stories but you can also take
the stories from Buddhism or you could
take the stories from Earth religions
even Evolution and we've been here for
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of years
every principle of the Bible
they negate
then they come out with a low data C
prayer book
you know even protestantism
in the beginning had the common book of
prayer and if you didn't pray that way
then you were thrown in jail
how dare you pray to God in your own
words
so if you have these repetitive prayers
that you can pray over and over and over
again and the Bible says be not like the
pagans who repeat over and over and over
again
imagine if you did that in your
relationship every day you start with
the same rituals and you repeat to your
wife or whatever you have learned to
recite
eventually the old bunks you over the
head with a pan
he left you I'm eventually I wonder if
she'll chase me out of the house maybe
correct now I wonder whether Mary
doesn't get bored with 10 Hail Mary's
one Our Father ten Hail Marys one Our
Father leaving the last part of our
father art in any case because he
shouldn't have dominion over everything
in the Kingdom forever and ever so
Martin this is this is very distressing
that the whole world is moving in the
direction of paganism whether they
belong to a religion or whether they
belong to atheism it doesn't make a
difference anymore and they do it with
the glue climate change it's a glue it's
for the common good and for Humanity and
it's Earth worship it is worshiping the
creature more than the Creator
now Newsweek reports on the 25th of
August that for our sins of emission 10
plus one climate Commandments
climate hope may not come from the 27th
Gathering
of the world leaders on the issue but
instead from a nearby place of Paramount
spiritual power
a group of us recently came together at
Mount Sinai
to Envision what message of Hope and
transformation religions can offer to
humanity as we grapple with the
challenges of climate Justice
now this is very interesting this is
Newsweek this is a secular magazine
and they're talking about 10 com 10
commandments plus one
and our sins of omission exactly
remember the pre our previous episode we
would
um focusing on the reality and the
secular world how that was in and we've
mentioned like you said we ended off is
this actually a religion
now we start seeing
the climate movement especially from
the Dao to see is definitely more of a
religious movement than actually a
secular movement Now isn't that
interesting Martin you've summarized
this that one of them is keep the
Sabbath
haven't we said this all along which
Sabbath is it going to be
of course it's going to be the the papal
Sabbath it has to be the sun worship
because brother son will be most annoyed
if you don't worship him in let alone
sister Moon
yes and eventually it will start off by
everybody can keep their own one by the
way but who is my mother and my brother
and my sister according to the scripture
isn't it those that keep the
Commandments yes and do the will of the
father
well emissions are down 30 over the
Sabbath every week in Israel and are
almost zeroed out on Yom Kippur the
Jewish Day of atonement the holiest of
the year
a global weekly non-carbon day of rest
could reduce emissions of the World by a
seventh and can be observed by different
Faith communities on different days on a
mother earth
Christina Grier 15 from California says
that climate change is a form of arson
against the very home that nurtures our
lives and that of all living creatures
and plus one
do not give up hope or the fight when
religious leaders of all faiths Ascend
Mount Sinai on November 13 during cop
27. they will seek to touch the heart of
humanity and deliver a prophetic message
Sinai power worked once before to fuel
moral revolutions it must work again I
just want to make a comment
Sanai
when the law was proclaimed what was the
first commandment
no other God I am the Lord your God that
took you out of Egypt very specific
you shall have no other gods before me
how many religions are climbing onto
this mountain now basically all so what
happened to the first commandment it's
gone that's why it's got to be new you
have to have new ones right plus one
foreign
we're laughing but it really isn't funny
no it's this is very serious that's the
problem we actually don't I don't think
people fathom how serious this is this
is very serious because this is the
final confrontation with the god of the
universe it is an affront to him yeah
that Humanity should collectively
including his so-called Representatives
set him aside
as though he were of no consequence
whatsoever you know what this whole
climate change is a Tower of Babel
because they're building this
against God because like he Pope
mentioned we have to save ourselves
well let's see how far he goes
Interfaith Center for sustainable
development
in Sinai a prophetic call for climate
Justice and ceremony of repentance
religious communities and religious
leaders have a key role to play in
addressing climate change and climate
Justice which requires deep
transformation within Society so is it a
religious movement oh sure definitely
okay
Mount Sinai is a mountain whose memory
and meaning Loom large as a place of
Revelation in the collective
consciousness of Christianity Judaism
Islam and others as an ancient Sacred
Space it was the site of prophetic
experience and receiving God's message
for the prophets Moses and Elijah in all
three abrahamic traditions
and the Prophet Muhammad in the Muslim
tradition cop 27 taking place in Sinai
can remind Humanity of our sacred
responsibility to care for God's
creation but what makes a place sacred
God
but it's just been removed then you
can't be sacred anymore there can't be a
sacred place it's the same as a Sabbath
if you remove God from it how can it be
holy still if you take Mount Carmel
it's a sacred place but there's Baha'i
Temple on it which speaks about the
wronged one I took the black picture
myself
speaks about the wronged one who's the
wronged one the one that was thrown out
of heaven right
we come to Sinai in a movement of
repentance and Quest we seek a new
vision for Humanity what's wrong with
the old Vision yeah I doubt it and
doesn't fit into their realm I thought
it was to last forever
and he added nothing more says the Bible
and these rules will stand to the close
of time not one jot or one title or by
any means disappear from the law until
everything everything has been
accomplished and what will happen to
those that
go and meddle with the words in the
prophecy and it's easier for heaven and
earth to disappear than for one judge or
one Tittle to disappear but they
obviously want to try and do their own
thing
and we seek to receive an amplifier
message of life-sustaining living and
habits that Humanity needs to hear today
the Elijah Interfaith Institute and its
Board of world religious leaders brings
together some of the world's most
prominent religious figures from Judaism
Islam Christianity Buddhism and the
religions of India that's all fine and
well
and I choose Sinai to make a new set of
Commandments that's actually Satan
making a statement
now when he chooses the Commandments if
they have negated them all
then obviously they're not going to take
the Sabbath they're going to take
another one yeah
Vatican news November the 3rd 2022 Pope
in Bahrain brings bring waters of
fraternity to Desert of human
coexistence it's a very busy man
especially for his age he's at 39 State
visits since his Ascension now Latimer
speaking to Ridley when they were being
martyred or before that
he asked him who is the most diligent
Bishop in all the world
and the answer was it is Satan he's
always at his post he's untiring in his
efforts
uh I don't know whether we should see
that as a comparison but we might as
well
I am here in this land of the tree of
life he said as the sower of Peace in
order to experience these days of
encounter
and to take part part in a form of
dialogue between East and West for the
sake of peaceful coexistence
the Holy Father which is a blasphemy in
itself emphasized the importance of
working tirelessly to confront the
climate emergency
and expressed his hope that the cop 27
meeting taking place in just a few days
in fact it's taking place right now
would be a step forward in this regard I
am here today as a Believer as a
Christian as a man as a pilgrim of Peace
the pope said because today more than
ever we are called everywhere to commit
ourselves seriously
to peacemaking
peace peace Martin peace and safety and
sudden destruction
now is it only the religious world or
must the political world come into
harmony
does the Vatican have political clout
again well didn't they say that he is
ascending to the throne basically of the
United Nations exactly
all right so let's get the United
Nations involved say yes to a world
United amongst people
urges the Holy See and this is from the
United Nations web page as you can see
so it is necessary to pass from the
strategies of political economic and
military power to a plan for Global
Peace no to a world divided amongst
conflicting powers
I believe that this war that is going on
in the Ukraine is all part and parcel of
the preparation to create a mindset
we want peace we finally want peace
exactly everything is affected by this
war apparently yes
so obviously and it coincides with all
this other so you've got this chaos on
the one side and this peace talk on the
other side
it is now up to each state party to key
International agreements on other
obligations incumbent upon them and to
implement such agreements the papal
Envoy said advocating for political will
at the upcoming U.N climate conference
cop 27 so it's a union of church and
state that's it
now once you have the state
enforcing religious Concepts and climate
change is a religion as we have seen and
it's a Pagan religion
and it's against God
because it has a different set of
Commandments and it reverses the
sequence and turns that which is written
for our admonition into a myth
well Martin then you have the perfect
recipe for a confrontation
finally you noted that the Holy See has
deposited instruments of accession
to the UN framework why do they use
those words all the time it sounds so
biblical it sounds like someone is
sending the throne convention on climate
change and Paris agreement becoming a
party to both prior to cop 27.
so there there's a lot resting on this
coming together
of various groups
now I understand Martin that someone
sent this to you just run us through
this yeah they mentioned that they had
this for quite a I think in 2011 quite a
few years back they took these pictures
in a old Jesuit Church in Rome and just
interesting to me that this model is a
temple but it you'll see if we read
through the description it
um represents all the religious
religions of the world and on top is a
statue of Jesus
but obviously it can't be the real Jesus
it must be a peg in Jesus and this fits
in actually perfect with this Mount
Sinai
situation that we've got yeah
so Martin here they have a model of a
temple embracing all religions
but there's a real place as well called
the pantheon where they also have
represented all the religions of the
world in this Roman setup so this has
been a plan for a long time
and this was written to you at this
stage and I think it's worth reading
as this person put it
an old Jesuit wooden model of the temple
covering all world religions in a Jesuit
Church
this is the Church of gizu this is the
main Church in Rome the seat of the
Jesuits okay
at the top of the Dome of the temple is
the statue of Jesus note obviously
cannot represent the real Jesus but the
power of the Pope apparently
representative of Jesus Christ on Earth
and stand above all religions and
denominations that makes sense
surrounding the center of the Dome
Temple are models of various temples of
world religions from mosques to
synagogues this model demonstrates the
vision of the Jesuit order and fits into
the context of current developments in
the religious and political Realm so it
has always been an objective of the
Jesuit order to unite all the religions
and all the political systems under the
curatorship and Leadership
of the pontifex Maxine yes that is the
aim of the Jesuit order in order to do
that it must destroy the true religion
true
so it is the enemy of righteousness
they are the enemy of God the most cruel
the most despotic order that has ever
disgraced this planet
and I can grieve a quote from the great
controversy to substantiate that for
those that are saying that I'm overly
harsh
and for that matter I can give you a
hundred quotes from the from the pens of
the reformers to say exactly the same
thing and then you have to remember
the current pope is a Jesuit
and we have nothing to fear from the
future lest we forget how God has led us
in the past that applies to the whole
Christian world and the Reformation
and it applies to the remnant as well as
well
now Martin once we start talking about
false jesuses and false Messiahs let's
just throw in what is happening in
Israel
I find it interesting that Israel's
Messiah
is possibly to be revealed very soon the
man in this video is known as the yanuka
rav shilomo Yehuda
he is uniting all the Jewish sects he
can quote the whole Torah and not only
that but he knows the Torah he has
quoted the whole Torah without a single
mistake and then takes questions
concerning the Torah and gives them an
answer showing them that he is yanuka
he has also been doing healings
foreign
but he also quotes the talmud
and the talmud has the very worst things
to say that you can possibly imagine
about Jesus Christ
and as to what the future condemnation
of Jesus Christ is going to be
so evil and so bad that I do not even
wish to quote it in this forum
this is a mixture and as soon as you
have a mixture you have Babylonian wine
and again you negate the one who is the
way the truth and the light and just
think of the repercussions that this was
going to have
everything is pretty
culminating into one the great disaster
as long as it's not Jesus
but all these false jesuses are actually
appearing exactly as the Bible said they
would exactly well even if you take
this mentioning that the Third Temple
will probably can be built next year
well the red heifer is there the perfect
one the the equipment has been restored
and rebuilt they are ready to build that
Temple and they want to start in 2023 as
far as I understand and now you see how
on time this Messiah is coming now not
one stone
will rest upon another your house will
be desolate to rebuild the Temple is a
blasphemy because it negates the
spiritual Temple that has been built and
to bring back offering is also a slap in
the face then you negate the anti-type
and you embrace the type
as far as religious festivals are
concerned
then I all have to be embraced and if we
can embrace them not only in the
religious sphere but we can embrace them
also in the political sphere how much
the better then we have this great Union
of all religions that they are working
towards
so let's look how Hollywood will further
this issue and how the governments
including the so-called Christian
nations like the United States of
America and the UK are embracing the
other religious festivals and giving
them prominence through the media
the time has come to recognize over two
hundred thousand New Yorkers of the
Hindu Buddhist Sikh and Jain faiths who
celebrate Diwali the Festival of Lights
and when we take this period to
acknowledge Duality we're acknowledging
the light that is within us the light
that clearly can push away darkness and
that is why this is so significant we
made this decision that uh this day that
we've always known traditionally as I
came up in the school system as Brooklyn
Queens day now it's anniversary day is
in many ways it's an obscure day it's a
day that's been on the calendar for a
long time I think it's the perfect
example of
a day that we could substitute that for
something much more meaningful much more
purposeful and something that I think
will have a great deal of relevance
foreign
at the White House
it's wonderful to be here with so many
friends
why celebrate light on the darkest night
when the moon is hardest to find
because that's when we need it most
these two
our president and first lady have once
again made this place
a place where every American
can celebrate and honor their Traditions
tonight of course we join with more than
one billion people around the world
to light the Daya
and to celebrate the fight
for good over evil
well Martin they made it quite clear
that what they celebrate is The Light
Within
now the Bible says of another individual
I am the light of the world yeah yeah
that's Jesus that's Jesus so is the
light within us
because we have light within ourselves
who introduced that idea to humanity
Lucifer Lucifer so when you celebrate
light you are celebrating the luciferian
initiation
and uh that's exactly what is happening
in the world today and the great
convocation the great day when he will
manifest
2025 according to Alison Bailey Martin
are we living in interesting times oh
for sure won't ye be presenting himself
as an angel of Light yes so now
victories can portray this as the King
of the North against the King of the
South but we must remember
that the King of the North the end time
King of the North under the papacy
represents all religions
so even if you have a pendulum swing
towards a Conservative Christian
Constitution
then it will still be a paganized
Christianity because it will be based on
papal principles this is how clever this
thing has been contrived
so the times of India was very happy to
to note that U.S Biden's hosts largest
ever Diwali reception at the White House
Ahmad it's interesting that
Biden wasn't the first it actually says
here since the people's house started
celebrating the festival during the
George Bush Administration
so there's another bonesman it seems
that the bonesmen are very busy with
their little chapters and secret
societies and secret handshakes and foul
little rituals that they perform doesn't
matter if you're on the left or on the
right doesn't matter they both are in
agreement on this Babylonian principle
and then the UK the guardian Rishi sunak
to become first British Prime Minister
of color and also first Hindu at number
10.
and he's about to become UK's prime
minister of color in the first Hindu
both milestones in British Evolution as
a multicultural and multi-faith Society
I have no beef with what people believe
everybody is entitled to their faith and
to study for themselves what is truth
and what is not truth
but once they start drawing you in and
paganizing Christianity then it's time
to raise a voice of warning
that I think also so acceptance
doesn't mean Conformity correct you
cannot you cannot change a person's
position in order to ensure Harmony
amongst the different systems we can
tolerate each other we can live side by
side but we cannot worship together no
and we especially because the climate
thing is like we've seen a religion it's
you cannot do it together no you cannot
so sunak is a practicing Hindu although
he has really talked publicly about his
faith he was named as the UK's next
leader on Diwali the Festival of Lights
celebrated by millions of Hindus and
here we can see him performing a
activity which aligns himself with the
festival so are these actually
stimuli for Humanity to accept all of
these things yeah yeah is the media
playing a magnificent role one of the
leading roles actually
all right so we have the religious world
we have the political world now we must
still have the financial world to be on
board as well right
so let's have a look of what these banks
are doing CBA expands rollout of carbon
footprint tracker with Westpac also
signing on so the bank the Commonwealth
Bank of Australia has announced it will
roll out a new personalized carbon
footprint tracking service
for retail customers following a
successful pilot of the technology last
October
so Martin are they going to
put CO2 meters on you on a breathalyzer
yeah well it's already on a card
so the bank can provide personalized and
granular information to customers about
how their spending translates to a
carbon footprint
cargo founder Ben glasner said banks are
ideally positioned to take on the role
of champion
in supporting their customers to lower
their carbon footprint now since this is
a religion
are they going to use finances to
enforce it for sure definitely they are
the champion that means no buying or
selling if they don't let you does it
fit all into the prophetic picture
so in a highly competitive market in
which it's hard to differentiate Banks
cannot ignore this opportunity to stand
out
and establish themselves as a lifestyle
partner to the conscious consumer
Martin they're going to force their
religion through the financial system
down your throat whether you like it or
not it's it now the funny thing is we're
probably the most carbon conscious of
many people that I know we use solar
power
the reason why we use solar Powers
because the government doesn't provide
real power so we have no choice
and in fact if we didn't have solar
power we couldn't produce these programs
yep because the power's out all the time
sometimes 10 hours a day sometimes 10
hours a day you're quite right
and so we have reduced carbon Footprints
substantially
but to push me into the direction of a
religious affiliation to this kind of
thing is contrary to what the Bible says
so Westpac also announced today it will
incorporate cogo's carbon footprint
tracking solution within its service
offerings or are they working together
so it's all coming together all of
coming together and I don't know if
other countries are the same but in
South Africa our counting our tax has
got a new law and everything companies
have to fill in and abide by certain
rules and actually have to report on
their carbon footprint yeah let's have a
look at another Mega company in this
regard this is Mastercard
press release unveils new carbon
calculator tool for banks globally as
consumer passion for the environment
grows who's fueling that passion
the boat and these and his advised at
the Dragon
the new Mastercard feature enables Banks
to equip people with carbon footprint
data and insights to help inform
consumer spending and offer ways to
contribute to reforestation
well Martin we can all
contribute by planting something in our
own Gardens I do not have to perform a
pagan ritualistic ceremony as the pope
did when pachamama was there with three
plantings and all of these issues
just do what you have to do in your
garden and get on with it so MasterCard
has also issued a 600 million
sustainability Bond and recently
announced changes to its executive
compensation model to help accelerate
progress around three Global ESG goals
carbon neutrality
Financial inclusion and gender pay
parity
interesting right
this is all in support of the company's
gold of building a more sustainable and
inclusive digital economy
Martin if people can't see where we're
heading then I'm afraid they've lost
their spiritual company you see and I I
just want to bring another thing in here
if you want to put the mark of the beast
on a chip or anything
even if you don't take it you're not
going to be able to buy or sell or if
you take this is the way it's going that
Mark cannot be a physical no
that Mark is exactly what Rome said it
was the fact that it has taken the
authority of God upon itself and has
transferred the Commandment of authority
from the Sabbath to the Sunday from God
to themselves
and then we have sunak of course who is
a champion of the digital currency he is
involved you not have to read at all
that's what he's going to do he's going
to call it britcoin
and he's not the only one all the other
governments in the world have said the
same the dollar is to be digitalized the
South African currency all the
currencies in the world this is a
coordinated effort exactly to to do what
and it's linked to religion that's it in
religion and to come back to the carbon
footprint and eventually that's linked
to religion again so you've got all
those links got it all
India to launch its own digital currency
in 2022 to 2023 what's the rush Martin
why is this all have to happen before
2025.
when their Master will finally hopefully
make an appearance
yeah and they can all Bow Down and
Worship Him but we have been warned that
when Jesus comes again he will not touch
this Earth he will not walk in here and
the elect will be raised from the grave
and they'll meet him in the air because
he's not going to walk down here so when
you hear that he's in the in a room or
whether you hear that he is somewhere in
Israel in the desert reciting the talmud
yeah then don't go and he won't you are
being deceived and he won't be on that
Mount Sinai
definitely not because God has been
removed from there
The Washington Post researchers warned
that Christian nationalists are becoming
more radical and are targeting voters
Martin is this our pendulum swing I
think so to another form of paganism
yeah
once again it's still under the same God
it's under the under the Garb of an
experiential religion it's under the
Garb of a seven Mountain Kingdom on this
Earth which is pure Jesuit Doctrine so
when they all run with it
then the Jesuits will be well pleased
because they're incorporating their
theology into into their thinking they
have rejected the Bible they have
rejected protestantism they have
rejected prophecy and the interpretation
based on the word and logic
and they have embraced a pile of potash
it's a sad state but it's called
Christian nationalism
and it will lead the world into a
christianized Pagan religion
as opposed to the other world religions
where the countries have embraced their
religions in their political sphere the
Islamic Nations is an Islam part of
their political structure even Bahrain
yes what about the Hinduism hasn't it
hasn't India been declared a Hindu
nation and Hinduism is part and parcel
of it that's it so you know it was very
clever to slice out Pakistan which is
more Islamic out of this so that they
can actually Proclaim these various uh
organizations so why not have a
Christian region as well which has been
thoroughly jesuitized
so grid a Christian nationalist wave is
testing U.S secularism overlapping
religion and politics like never before
a nation of blue religion and red
religion is causing some Americans to
lose faith and others to win elections
the politicization of religion in the
United States can be found increasingly
in the highest places of power and
persuasion
and at least along party lines there is
also significant public support to drop
the separation of church and state and
just go with quite literally Church
well we already have governments working
together with the Pagan religions why
not with the paganized Christianity
as long as it's not true Christianity
the devil is perfectly happy he wants
you to be in your Utopia of deception
you know what true Christianity the
biblical Christianity will in any case
never be there because we won't
it will actually be there Martin but as
a Remnant alone but who is crying in the
world yes but I mean not as a state
Church State entity so true Christianity
will never join do this joining it will
never do it you're right
it's interesting this article from Fox
News left-wing activist Harris
conservative
reading Bible
steel book and rip it up protesters eat
the pages so Martin there was this man
he was reading the Bible
they walked up to him ripped the Bible
out of his hand pull the pages up and
started eating the pages they're taking
the Bible very literally because the
Bible said and your word came and I ate
it and it was in my mother's sweet as
honey but in my stomach
well like you said hopefully
internalizes it yes so hopefully he
internalized what I internalized what
they read maybe they read something
significant but this is how ridiculous
it is I've seen videos
of people kicking the Bible around
and uh it's just such an animosity
between the two groups and maybe this
must grow to the point where religious
laws become so stringent
that anybody who dares to oppose them
will face the Wrath of the state
well Martin let us wrap this up with a
discussion of all of what is happening
in the world and how Rome for example
sees the role of the priesthood it is
important because Rome is the moral
compass of the world and that it Pope
obviously with this whole letter that
we've been discussing seems to be the
global leader he is the global leader
and you can see the position that he
holds he's always in the central
position he's always wearing white
representing his own righteousness and
negating the righteousness of Christ so
let's have a look at the official
teaching of the Roman Church regarding
the priesthood
this is dignity and duties of the priest
by Alphonsus de ligurre
and declared a doctor of the Catholic
church in 1871 by Pope Pius we're only
going to read the underlined portions
but of course they always have their
Saints the Epistles to the Christians of
Smyrna sent Ignatius Marta says that the
priesthood is the most Sublime of all
created dignities of course ignazius
would be in there right
so Saint Christ the psalm says that
though it functions are performed on
Earth the priesthood should be numbered
amongst the things of Heaven
now we must reiterate a priest is
someone who brings a sacrifice
a Protestant Minister cannot be a priest
it can only be a minister
it can only serve to minister is to
serve but these priests are individuals
that bring a sacrifice what sacrifice do
they want to bring if through one
sacrifice Christ has already made
perfect right
so according to Cassian the priest of
God is exalted above all Earthly
sovereignties and above all Celestial
Heights
I saw that little video of Biden talking
to a young whippersnapper priest and
calling him father
which sort of demonstrates you know this
hierarchy
is inferior only to God
innocent the third says
do you have any quotes from The Bible
here no only by these so-called Saints
it and innocent the third says that the
priest is placed between God and man I
thought Christ was the mediated at it
and the only mediator nobody comes to
the father except by me but yeah they've
got someone else right
but Superior to man
that's a problem that's a major problem
let's just see how Superior they can
become hmm
Saint Denis calls the priest a Divine
man that's a blasphemy
hence he has called the priesthood a
Divine dignity
in fine Saint Ephraim says that the gift
of the sacredotal dignity surpasses all
understanding
I admit that my understanding is
exceedingly challenged when I look at
the Modern priesthood
through respect for the sacredotal
dignity Saint Mary of oiknus used to
kiss the ground on which a priest had
walked
and uh the great John who wrote the
Revelation fell at the feet of an Angel
and the angel reprimanded him but here
we seem to have the opposite yeah
Martin I am nauseated already but for
the sake of suffrage we will continue
Divine says sensorial of Alexandria
we must maybe just
emphasize
they quoting here their most respected
Saints yes it's so it's not some obscure
document document no
Are the officers confided to priests
Saint Ambrose has called the Priestly
office a Divine profession the entire
church cannot give to God as much honor
nor obtain so many Graces as a single
priest by celebrating a single mass for
the greatest honor that the whole church
without priests could give to God would
consist in offering to him in sacrifice
the lives of all men
this is paganism
all nations are before him as if they
had no being at all
so we are as nothing compared to a
priest Martin
thus by the celebration of a single mass
in which he offers Jesus Christ in
sacrifice for those being offered once
for all and no more sacrifices needed
according to the scripture and Jesus was
the sacrifice yes a priest gives greater
honor to the Lord than if all men by
dying for God offered to him the
sacrifice of their lives
Jesus has died to Institute the
priesthood
no I thought he opened the way to direct
communication with God
that's it
anyone who comes to me I will by no
means turn back
it was not necessary for the Redeemer to
die in order to save the world a drop of
his blood a single tear or prayer was
sufficient to procure salvation for all
for such a prayer being of infinite
value would be sufficient to save not
one but a thousand worlds Martin
this is negating the sacrifice that
Christ and reducing it to Works a tear
would have done it yeah no without blood
there is no remission of sins Jesus Paid
the price in its full this is a
blasphemy
but to Institute the priesthood the
death of Jesus has been necessary
and that is absolutely true
they had to kill Jesus in order to
elevate themselves to the level of
priests and they keep him dead through
the mass
because there is not one second on earth
when there is another Mass red to make
sure absolutely sure that Jesus stays
dead
who would want that
but Satan Satan wants it so the mass is
the satanic Institution
and transubstantiation
is an evil contriving because the Bible
is quite clear it is in remembrance of
what he did not a repeat of what was
done
and then we can remind everybody that
this institution is the one leading the
world to get unity and peace and these
holy priests that are Divine and that
the whole world could die and it
wouldn't be as important as what one
Little Priest can do this brings us to
another point this is the 7th of
November
2022. that's pretty current right
French Cardinals Jean-Pierre record has
been named by the church as one of 11
serving or former Bishops accused of
sexual violence
in its report on October 2021 an
independent commission set up by the
Catholic church in France this is one
country Martin
found that some 216
000 children
have been abused since the 1950s
largely boys aged 10 to 13.
the head of the panel said there was
evidence that up to 3 200 abusers and
evidence had been handed to the
prosecutors in 22 cases where criminal
action could still be launched
France is one of many countries where
sexual abuse allegations have rocked the
Roman Catholic Church Martin
3200 abusers
in my lifetime this is since 1950
000 children abused
now what about all the children that
were abused and murdered in Canada or
the United States or everywhere else in
the world by those so-called gods
whose ground has to be kissed when they
walk over it
Martin this is a diabolical system it's
true because you see the problem is
people can now say yes but there are
people like this in every denomination
there's a difference
because like we've always said
you must see what the teaching of the
denomination says and we've read
previously what this denomination says
of these priests and what did they do
with them throughout history nothing
transferred them to another place where
they continued their Divine Act of
gracing the ground with their presence
and abusing more children
this is something that is horrendous and
sin is horrendous no matter what
denomination it occurs in but this
particular denomination seems to be the
champion of them all but besides the
physical abuse
and this Cardinal abuse the little 14
year old girl
besides the physical abuse what about
the mental abuse
that has taken place of the World by
implanting the most horrendous doctrines
into the minds of men
and taking them away from faith in a God
that loves you well if we take it that
this whole climate change
is a mental Distortion from this now the
Bible has promised Martin
that whatever is done is in secret will
be shouted from the rooftop
whatever is done in secret will be made
manifest
God has made sure that everything has
been revealed
and in spite of it
they're going to choose the system
they're going to act as if none of it
mattered there'll be a momentary Ripple
it will be swept under the carpet and
the world will follow this diabolical
system all the way to Perdition
unless they see the light and they will
do it with Wonder they'll wander after
it
so Martin when it comes to this issue of
what is happening in the world today and
the new Commandments that are being
contrived at Mount Sinai as for me and
my house
we will serve the old
because not one jot or one Turtle will
by any means disappear from the law
until all has been accomplished let's
pray thank you
Heavenly Father
what a horrendous system
and the world is following it like a
festival of lights
but that light
is not a light that comes from you
it is a false light it is a luciferian
light
and I pray that the True Light
may take over the world
and that many will see it separate
themselves from Babylon
and embrace the truth as it is in Jesus
amen amen
thank you